so yesterday as you know we traveled to
Florida to interview the king of talk
radio one of the conservative thought
leaders in the country for the last 30
years rush limbaugh and here's part two
of our exclusive interview I talked to
two friends that I know those sit and
closed-door meetings with the Senate
right and you've got a bunch of senators
in there I'll name names Ben Sasse John
McCain others openly hostile towards the
president which raises a question I've
always kind of use myself as a Reagan
conservative I remember you teaching
people about Reagan and taxes and and
Kennedy and taxes and playing all clips
of these things and I remember it worked
you just mentioned Reagan it worked what
do they stand for if they're not going
to stand for repeal replace in this
economic plan and do you believe they
really want this plan to go through or
are they setting the country up for yet
another failure
well intelligence guided by experience
they've introduced it just like they did
Obamacare let's see how how tough how
far they take this how much they fight
for it or whether they just want to try
to get the credit for proposing it but
they answer your question it goes back I
think to election night they didn't
expect Trump to win and they weren't
prepared for Trump to win and they're
still unhappy that Trump won and I I
think the real answer to your question
is Washington establishment of both
parties it's a small club its elite you
can't get in it because you want to get
in it it's a rental clubhouse I mean but
Trump would never be admitted in this
club no matter what he did these guys
have been running the country its donors
its think tanks it's the whole wash of
media the whole establishment Trump's an
outsider they have been managing the
country ruling the country for however
many decades they can't afford for an
outsider neophyte to come in and redo
everything fix things in three months
fix things in a year show that it can be
done show that an outsider can do it
show that what they say can't be done
can be done I think there
and there are all United Republicans and
Democrats it's not just the Senate in
making sure that Trump the outsider
doesn't succeed with his agenda don't
they pay a price they made this promises
here's the thing you you tell me I mean
you you you're closer to these people on
daily basis than I am
who are they loyal to their donors the
donors matter more than their voters
obviously this Obamacare thing
who doesn't want Obamacare gotten rid of
the insurance companies probably the
chamber commerce any number of usual big
donors and the people who really write
the legislation in Washington on K
Street they don't want it done away with
but Rush Limbaugh fans that have been
dedicated to you for all these years
what your thirty years now on the radio
twenty-nine in town all right
twenty-nine County did listening to this
they got everything they want House
Senate and a president that wants to do
these things right what I'm deflated at
times
I'm deflated they couldn't get health
care done I'm like seriously they have
their seven years you can't get this
done well I look I'm deflated too but
I'm more angry about it but I think I
understand it look at Alabama the answer
to this is what happened in Alabama in
terms of the voters everybody is saying
that that vote in Alabama was an
indication that Trump's base is leaving
him that's what they want everybody is
trying to make sure that Trump's base
leaves him because they can't cause it
they've been trying to do that since
before he was inaugurated only Trump can
destroy that relationship but they're
trying so Trump endorses the wrong guy
as far as his voters are concerned what
do they do they elect the right guy but
they don't abandon the Trump they had
his back on that vote they are so
invested in Trump because he's the only
way what they believe can happen they're
not going to abandon the Trump even when
he makes a mistake they're gonna have
his back all these stories Trump was
livid Trump was angry that maybe so but
he should be very thankful that his
voters are sophisticated enough to
understand that they're going to do
everything they can to help him move his
agenda forward and that's what that
Alabama vote was about I think more than
anybody the person in America you
fine conservatism Reagan conservatism
now we keep hearing well this is
nationalism populism I look at the
President's agenda I have some
disagreements not many I think he's got
a strong agenda of growth it would be
good for the originalist on the court we
can securing the border you talk about
national populism versus conservatism a
lot do you see his agenda as
conservative national populism is there
conflict I don't think the president is
ideological one yeah and I I've said
this a number of times he when he sees
Chuck Schumer he doesn't see the guy we
see he just sees a typical New Yorker
maybe dumb and stupid but he doesn't see
leftist sob there's not a criticism I
mean not everybody is ideological the
best definition of populism versus
conservatism this tax plan this tax plan
is pure populism it is put together on
the belief which is a Democrat Party
belief that a majority of Americans want
the rich punished or that a majority of
Americans want the rich not to benefit
when they do that's a Democrat Party
class and the argument if what I'm told
is true and if the president is the
reason upper brackets are not going to
get any relief then it's pure populism
he's simply saying where is the majority
of people that I can get the most
support from and he's making a
calculation that are far more people of
middle class than there are the 1% which
is an easy calculation to make the
conservative and I don't even mean pure
the conservative philosophy of this
across the board no class envy talk
about how Great America is talk about
how this will spur economic growth which
will benefit everybody
you don't make victims out of some and
demons out of other you'd look at the
country is one giant economic engine
that you have to ignite but if you're
going to leave people out of your
primary effort to cause growth that's
populism that's not conservative on
individual Trump policies the
immigration he's instinctively
conservative on a lot of
whether he sits in his offices I'm gonna
do I'm gonna go for the serve on this in
support I don't think that happens his
instincts his heart
95% right there I agree so really if you
go to seven brackets the three you
simplify the tax code fifteen twenty
percent corporate rate were patreon I
love his energy plan energy independence
that's gonna create a lot of jobs in my
opinion and so the real missing
ingredient is he's just bought into what
we can't we have to still tax the rich
more they've got enough that's the
missing part of say the Reagan formula
right well and that's but see that's a
liberal argument and that they've got
enough whose business is it to decide
who has enough when especially you're
going to say we have to find a way to
pay for this
who's we government why can't government
do with a dollar less next year when
they demand more from us we can't say no
no we can't afford it out of here they
demand it they take it they got a giant
collection agency they never do it so we
have however many years that you and
I've been doing this the budgets never
gotten smaller the deficit over time has
been opened down but the national debt
keeps going doesn't matter which parties
in power
535 people and however many people in
the bureaucracy are ruining this country
not us we're doing our best we're doing
everything we can we we elect the people
we think based on what they say that was
our honest and and agree with us but at
the end of the day all of this rhetoric
about reducing the deficit reducing the
national debt making government smaller
more efficient it never happens
[Music]